[Music]
thank you
ladies and gentlemen
on behalf of the fdth council Europe it
is my great pleasure to officially open
our ftth conference 2023 in Madrid the
wonderful capital of Spain
a famous philosopher once said you can't
buy happiness
but you can buy a plane ticket to Madrid
and that's pretty much the same thing
I hear and I see you concur
now the momentum for fiber has been
growing at a stunning speed in recent
years 15 years ago
our beloved European continent wondered
if fiber was really necessary
over the course of the 2010s the belief
grew that fiber would become inevitable
and indispensable
today every one of us is aware of the
need for full fiber connectivity to
safeguard resilience for our societies
and prepare our future prosperity
we evolved from why fiber over how fiber
to fiber to connect everything and
everyone everywhere
very high capacity networks based on
fiber access or the backbone of Digital
Society and full fiber is the most
sustainable and future-proof Technology
enabling All Digital applications we
will need in the years and decades to
come
but where do we stand today
coverage figures for fiber to the home
in Europe amount to 62 percent today
and they are expanding rapidly
we noticed that many ambitious programs
and projects will lead us to more fiber
connectivity throughout the coming years
promising
but that doesn't mean the job is done
some countries in Europe have yet to
reach more than half of their households
with fiber
but we observe positive Trends in UK
Germany Italy Belgium and others where
the acceleration to full fiber
connectivity has now really been
launched
the European commission as well as
member states are setting ambitious
targets and private investors are
supporting this massive rollout effort
our sector is at the heart of the twin
green and digital transition which is a
top priority
for the EU
we see public policies and the European
regulatory framework as very favorable
to the development of ftth networks and
we will take the opportunity of this
event to discuss more in detail how they
can be further enhanced and implemented
in member countries
we want Europe's digital decade program
stating that every European household by
2030 should have access to a gigabit
Network to find its implementation with
secure and sustainable digital
infrastructures
this is a bow
's Vision that reflects our Collective
commitment to building a more connected
and inclusive Europe
we applaud that at least 20 percent
of the recovery and resilience facility
funds are being dedicated to digital
transition
the connectivity topic is very high on
the agenda of our policy and Regulatory
bodies and the timing of our conference
could not be more ideal
we are looking forward to a speedy
adoption of the gigabit infrastructure
Act
which is replacing the Broadband cost
reduction directive proposed by the
European Commission
much can still be done to accelerate and
simplify the deployment process
so a timely approval of the gigabit
infrastructure act can truly contribute
to accelerating rollout
bringing us one step closer to achieving
that goal for a fully connected Europe
in addition the gigabit connectivity
recommendation document advising how
gigabit connectivity should be promoted
from a regulatory point of view has
sparked many conversations among experts
and stakeholders alike
the ftth council Europe has carefully
examined the draft recommendation and we
have conveyed to the European commission
our position
in which we welcome the various positive
aspects while advising against some
potential risks
I'm sure that these topics will be
touched upon in many of the conference
panels
now during this two-day conference we
will as always launch and present our
latest Market Panorama including the
global ranking forecast
2023-2027 and ftth fttb in rural areas
you will notice that adoption of ftth
today averages 30 percent across
European households
now to accelerate the adoption of ftth
we launched a study called ftth adoption
drivers and hurdles in Europe conducted
by Benoit Felton of Plum Consulting
and he develops a series of
recommendations for both policy makers
and Industry Executives on how to
increase uptake of fdth
end user satisfaction strongly depends
on how the potential of the fiber
network is maximized thanks to
appropriate Solutions in end user
premises
our second version of the in-home
Broadband Excellence handbook
describe scenarios for service providers
to avoid churn and accelerate
monetization by selling value-added
services
but fiber serves more than only
consumers it connects everyone and
everything everywhere
in addition to the ever growing and end
user demand for bandwidth Enterprises
need reliable and resilient high-speed
internet and multi-site connectivity
airports hospitals schools and
universities hotels holiday Resorts they
refurbish their local area networks with
fiber to serve their employees and
customers in a better way by means of
future proof and sustainable
Technologies
cities are digitalizing as we speak and
fiber offers unlimited possibilities for
smart applications to be enabled
5G and ftth
go hand in hand and fiber is the
Cornerstone of a successful conversion
strategy for Network operators
once 5G cell densification really takes
off
you can easily state that
a mobile network is in fact a fiber
network with a bit of Wireless at the
end don't you think
Next Generation Pond Technologies
are developed and deployed to adequately
meet the demand for fiber for everything
and everywhere
climate change and cutting emissions are
on the political agenda in bold letters
Legacy to fiber migration and evolution
to Next Generation technologies will
lead to increased traffic handling
capacity while keeping energy
consumption Limited
sustainability action plans in ftth
Industry will be discussed
our newborn sustainability committee
will actively promote fiber as the most
sustainable access technology and will
help any member company that is part of
the ftth value chain to measure report
and reduce their carbon footprint in the
years to come
now the ftth conference brings together
ftth experts from every European country
and Beyond
policy makers Regulators Network
operators service providers and
Technology Specialists are here to
discuss the latest evolutions of this
exciting Market
we do our best to offer you the ideal
environment for information sharing
business networking and we are delighted
to welcome you to this world's largest
fiber Summit in the center of Europe
I've just been informed that we have
registered more than 3 000 delegates
from 88
that's far more than the EU from 88
countries
so I would say Enjoy the networking
moments and possibilities
fiber for everyone
everywhere
becomes a reality more and more
15 years ago
we were like Don Quixote
fighting windmills and pursuing our
dreams
today
we are like Sancho Panza facing reality
and witnessing full fiber connectivity
coming closer and closer we wish you a
very good event thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you